I wanna talk to you a little bit about
friction fire the tools that you need
are you need your hearth board you need
a spindle and you also need a nest with
a nest I like to start out with the my
longer fibers
I'll just twist those around to form a
little bit of a pocket with the tinder
nest you want everything pretty tight so
at the spindle and hearth you want
something fairly light but most
important it's the grain structure if
you look at this one you would see
little grains almost little holes and
pores in here so you want to make a
starter hole so I make a divot in there
you can sit on here your butt like this
or another technique that helps is you
get get up on above it either on both
knees or one knee you can sometimes put
a little bit more weight on it this way
what the starter hole just want to get
to that point or just start smoking
so the knotch basically I start by
cutting at the top because I can see it
and it's basically like cutting on a
piece of pie what it's doing is allowing
the pump to accumulate one spot once you
have that prepared you want something to
catch the coal like this wood chip or a
leaf or something set it down nice and
secure we want you ready and we make
sure your hands have enough friction on
the spindle you can either spit on it or
if you run out of spit you can have a
little bit of water nearby rub that in
your hands the key is you're putting a
lot more pressure on it than yours so
I'm actually pushing really hard inward
and downward at the same time and that
that driving force what's gonna beats
the coal so as you're going once you see
that basically you have smoke coming out
of out of the pile of punk at that point
you can stop tap any leftover Punk on it
I'll keep going you can see it's it's
red-hot and then it dropped the coal in
the nest
seems counterintuitive but you want to
squeeze that nest and really cradle that
coal way down in there deep breath you
want to increase the breath hardness as
it starts spreading
that's it you want to turn it on its
side towards the wind hey you got a fire
and that's it that's that's friction
fire in a nutshell right there